so obviously you and nips here from the
same area yeah
um what is
I feel like it's hard to kind of like
for people who aren't from LA to like
understand like how big of a loss he was
nip is like and our Tupac and I kind of
I mean like and I love Kobe right but I
feel like
Kobe dying hit me really hard right it
was [ __ ] up it hit the world hard but
I feel like Nipsey dying hit La harder
oh bro that that was like Kobe's like
just lost we ever took ever as a city
him and Kobe I would say nip number one
and no for sure Kobe but I'm just saying
it's crazy because I I would be number
two because I cried on you could cut it
with a [ __ ] knife in L.A bro
Unk had people from hoods that would
their certain hoods in L.A that don't be
around each other no matter what and I
try to trade carefully interviews
because I don't really like to say like
what hood is what and all that [ __ ]
because you know I you know uh but no I
mean he had that day where everybody
United bro that's what I'm that's what
I'm trying to say like bro it's been
there's hoods in La that don't be around
each other no matter what like it's
instant smoke you know I mean and UNC
had everybody all in one spot all
together
coming together for nip and that just
goes to show you how great nip is and
how great uncle is you know what I mean
because like those two right there bro
like
everybody you don't like everybody in
South Central
looked up to Nick no matter what where
are you from they don't matter where the
[ __ ] you from like even the people that
hated nip
end up having to end up having to be
like damn like that's that guy you feel
me like yeah at the the end of the day
and like nip just show all of us
in L.A that like man we all could do
this [ __ ] you know what I mean like we
all can do this [ __ ] and he he and it
was like
nip was just a whole whole different
energy than most people because like he
was just so so intelligent right you
know I mean and when and when and when
you get that like a realness with that
authenticity it's like it's a whole
different breed bro and not many not
many people can ever hold a candle to
nip in in
uh the LA no matter what just for sure
just off his [ __ ] impact overall to
everybody you know what I mean like
that's the goat man so if nipsey's
passing can bring that many people
together who would usually be on site
with how do you keep that energy going
does everyone just need to smoke DMT man
that's the problem bro like
because that's cool everyone that comes
together for a day but then what happens
like two weeks later or exactly right
six years later you know honestly we
just need people that are more like
Uncle Nick like you know I mean like we
need more people like that that can
really lead youth in a positive
different direction you know what I'm
saying like I hate to say it but you
know the little like what's some little
dudes names a little like uh a jungle
Stone whatever you know what I'm saying
maybe it's not gross whatever the [ __ ]
that is not it bro like that that that
type of energy that's the [ __ ] that that
hold us back you know what I mean and uh
I have to say like bro like like that
type of [ __ ] is
it needs to be redirected because
obviously like like a lot of these kids
got talent and all that but they putting
it in into the wrong [ __ ] you know what
I mean yeah I mean I had them on come up
here and freestyle and they seem like
nice kids you know but I mean they're
kids though yeah but that's what I'm
saying there's like uh growth involved
in all that but I feel like we need like
more like OG's and like not even OG's
like geez like nip you feel me like more
people need to set an example it's like
this is what we trying to push man we
ain't on that type time like you know I
mean like more people have to speak up
and stop trying to be cool and just fit
in with everybody else and copy what
everybody else is doing and really just
like be like true to themselves and say
like hey this is the type of music that
we doing like like the the the music
culture in
the LA has been changing a little bit
because the artists like
a blast and albino and [ __ ] like that
exactly like I feel like that's kind of
that's that's also helping you know what
I mean because it kind of a Roddy Rich
it kind of shares a different light on
and I think too even like some of the
like like the one take Jays of the world
yeah exactly like those guys are like
not necessarily letting politics get in
the way exactly that's what I'm saying
and I feel like the younger kids at
least most I mean a lot of the younger
generation of La rap
they seem to be more united than I've
seen previous generations maybe because
they're not as a like heavily Affiliated
and then even the artists that are you
know like obviously there's artists that
don't [ __ ] with each I just saw the baby
Stone guy in the ASM bobster guy going
back and forth on Instagram like Jesus
Christ